[MUSIC PLAYING]
How far would you go to
charge your cell phone
if you had no electricity?
Would you walk for hours?
Miles?
That's what millions of people
across sub-Saharan Africa
do every day simply to
charge their phones.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: I'm Here in Tanzania
because sub-Saharan Africa
is experiencing a
major energy crisis.
Modern-day Africa has been
transformed by cell phones,
but the infrastructure needed
to charge those phones,
and to power sub-Saharan Africa
in general, just isn't there.
And it's leaving hundreds of
millions of people in the dark.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the village of Mkuranga,
I immediately felt welcomed.
Since most people don't have
electricity in their homes,
they go to charging stations
to power their phones.
Recho Mango, a health care
provider at the local clinic,
was picking up her cellphone
that she paid roughly $0.20
to charge.
Hi, I'm Laura.
Nice to meet you.
RECHO MENGO: Nice to meet you.
LAURA LING: She took me to her
clinic's maternity ward, which
has no power.
So this is the clinic?
RECHO MENGO: Yeah,
this is the clinic.
LAURA LING: Do you often have
to deliver babies in the dark
because there's no light?
Vital immunizations for
mothers and children
are kept cool by gas
from a propane tank.
It's getting dark
out, and Recho is
about to see a client who
is in her third trimester
of pregnancy.
And she could give
birth at any moment.
So Recho basically
has to do whatever
she can just make it work.
According to the World
Health Organization,
women in developing
countries such as Tanzania
are dying every 90
seconds from complications
during pregnancy or childbirth.
Would having adequate
light save lives?
While a few homes in
this town are connected
to an electrical grid,
they often experience
frequent blackouts, sometimes
lasting up to 48 hours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
18-year-old Hussein Mwende
has lived his entire life
without ever having
electricity in his home.
What you want to be
when you grow up?
It sounds extremely
difficult. Do
you ever feel like giving up?
Mkuranga is typical of many
villages across Tanzania.
Just a few hours away is
Tanzania's largest city,
Dar es Salaam.
It might seem surprising,
but Africa has the world's
fastest-growing middle class.
While there still is a long
way to go, signs of development
are all around.
At [? Nelwa's ?] Gelato shop,
I met owner Mercy Kitomari.
How many gelato shops are
there in Dar es Salaam.
MERCY KITOMARI: So
there's, like, five.
LAURA LING: In all
of Dar er Salaam?
MERCY KITOMARI: In Tanzania.
LAURA LING: In all Tanzania?
MERCY KITOMARI: Yeah.
LAURA LING: Why do you think
that there are some few.
MERCY KITOMARI: The costs.
An average person won't even
think of doing this business
because when they
think of power cuts,
you don't even think
following that.
LAURA LING: There's
a blackout right now.
You have a generator.
That's why we hear this
little buzz in the air.
MERCY KITOMARI: Yeah, yeah.
And it's often.
LAURA LING: It seems
extremely challenging to have
this kind of business in a
country with so many blackouts.
MERCY KITOMARI: It
does slow you down.
When power cuts off, the
first thing is the freezers.
You freak out.
I started thinking, oh, shit.
Need to hire a generator.
You hire a car to bring it.
You hire a crane to lift it.
And for the generator,
they charge you per hour.
LAURA LING: So it's
very expensive.
MERCY KITOMARI: Yes.
LAURA LING: And meanwhile,
your gelato is melting.
MERCY KITOMARI: Yeah.
LAURA LING: Is it
worth it to you?
MERCY KITOMARI: It is.
It has been worth it.
It's been super challenging.
Super, super challenging.
But every day, there's progress.
LAURA LING: Mercy
relies on social media
to build her business.
In many ways, her
entrepreneurial spirit
represents Africa's
enormous potential.
But energy issues may determine
how bright that future will be.
MERCY KITOMARI: I love my
country, don't get me wrong.
But there's still a
lot of work to be done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: It's Saturday night
here in Mkuranga, Tanzania.
And we're going to do
what the locals do.
We're going to go to the movies
at the local movie theater.
They're playing a
local Tanzanian movie.
It's called [? Gengue. ?]
Is it it good?
Do you like it?
SUBJECT: Very good.
LAURA LING: Good.
Most people in this town
don't have electricity,
so they come here
for entertainment.
Luckily, this place
has a generator.
When blackouts occur,
life proceeds for those
that can afford a generator.
But for those that can't,
it's a different story.
There's a blackout going on
right now in this neighborhood.
Everything around
me is pitch black.
The stores have closed.
The only light is
really this candle
and whatever motorcycles
and cars pass down the road.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It seems strange and
a little unsettling
to be in near total darkness
that was beyond my control.
But those around me
didn't seem fazed.
This is life as normal here,
and in pretty much the rest
of sub-Saharan Africa.
Thinking back on
the people I'd met,
they were making it
work despite challenges.
And if power never
arrives, I'm sure they'll
keep plugging away, determined
to make a better life
for themselves and for others.
But charging stations and
generators will only go so far.
These are some of the
friendliest and supportive
people I've ever met.
They deserve better,
and I wish them well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Watch this next episode
to me Hussein's mom
and see why she reacts this
way to the idea of electricity.
How do you think your life
would be different if you
had access to reliable energy?
[LAUGHING]
To learn more about energy
poverty, visit one.org/energy.
Thanks for watching and
be sure to subscribe
to "Seeker Stories."
[MUSIC PLAYING]